[Music]  [Music]  what  [Applause]  [Music]  another  yoland is part of a small group of women  affectionately known as the solar  grandmothers  they live in the rural village of  embacabao in madagascar and volunteered  to become trained solar engineers so  they could bring light to their  community  routing  [Music]  the grandmas have installed more than  200 solar panels and repair broken ones  [Music]  before the solar panels people in town  were using firewood and gas lamps when  the sun went down which is bad for the  environment and a fire hazard the solar  energy that the panels collect during  the day gives the community a safe  alternative at night  [Music]  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  you